PAUL KINLAN: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to our talk.
There's a lot of
people in here.
We didn't actually expect this
many people, did we?
No.
So hello everyone.
Welcome to Mobile HTML, the
Future of Your Sites.
PETER BEVERLOO: My name is--
PAUL KINLAN: You on?
PETER BEVERLOO: No.
I think it's not.
My name is Peter Beverloo.
I'm a software engineer
at Google.
I work with Chrome
for Android.
And I mostly specialize in--
PAUL KINLAN: Yay.
PETER BEVERLOO: Hello?
Yeah, this sounds better.
PAUL KINLAN: Yay.
[APPLAUSE]
PETER BEVERLOO: So my name
is Peter Beverloo.
I'm a software engineer
at Google.
I work on the Chrome
for Android team.
And I mostly specialize
in pushing the
web platform forwards.
PAUL KINLAN: I'm Paul Kinlan, a
developer advocate on Chrome.
I specialize in the
mobile web.
And you can catch me at all
these normal places.
So should we get started?
PETER BEVERLOO: Sounds good.
PAUL KINLAN: We should
get into it.
So it's always good to start
with a survey, and kind of
understand how everyone in this
room deals with mobile.
So I want everyone to put your
hand up if you have a
smartphone.
Pretty sure that's--
yeah, keep it up, keep it up.
You've got to keep it up.
Right.
So who has a 24 inch
smartphone?
One person has got a 24 inch?
How big?
Come on, show it please.
Have you got it?
I actually, the reason why I'm
kind of looking dumbfounded is
because I actually realized
I'd forgotten to enter the
number of the person
I'm calling.
So who has a dual
24 inch screen?
OK.
I've actually designed
all these slides
for a 24 inch screen.
PETER BEVERLOO: It's a little
bit of a bummer.
PAUL KINLAN: Man.
So who loves typing
on a phone?
OK, no one.
That's cool.
Who has a gigabit ethernet
connected phone?
No?
Who's got like a
5G, a 4G phone?
A couple of people are getting
really fast phones now.
It's kind of interesting.
And who uses their phone
as their primary
desktop type of device?
You know, this is a kind of
interesting one, this one.
Because if you're kind of
working out and about and not
a developer, this actually is
going to be one of those
things that happens in
the near future.
Where your primary machine
actually is your phone.
So I know I'm being a bit kind
of like facetious with the
photos and all this
type of stuff.
But what we're trying to say is
that mobile is different.
And the way that we're building
our sites and
application at the moment, we're
still not targeting this
mobile web, which is, if you
look at India, for instance,
like 60% of the traffic
is mobile based.
And we're still not building
applications and sites that
cater for that.
PETER BEVERLOO: So probably the
most obvious difference
between desktop machines and
mobile devices is that the
screen is significantly
smaller.
So as developers, we've got
less space to play with.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
And I use the mobile, right?
I know the word is mobile when
we're talking about mobile web
development.
But our users are
out and about.
And can we take advantage of the
fact that they might be in
a shopping mall, they might be
on the street, they might be
driving down the road.
They might actually have this
thing where they don't have a
great internet connection.
And can we build applications
and sites which are
responsive to this?
PETER BEVERLOO: And even though
you are the kind of
person who likes writing an
essay on a mobile phone, I
absolutely hate typing
on these devices.
PAUL KINLAN: And most of our
sites also, or most of our
apps, at least, or devices
have unique hardware
capabilities.
Everyone phone has a GPS
receiver, a camera, and a
whole host of other kind of
really interesting features
that we just don't get
on the desktop web.
And what can we do to take
advantage of that today?
PETER BEVERLOO: And then of
course, everything is slower
on a mobile device.
It's not just the screen
which is slower.
But because the whole device is
slower, we actually don't
have the space available to
put in a big ass GPU so to
speak on a desktop machine.
So in this presentation today,
we're going to talk a little
bit about features which are
available on the web today
which are being developed, and a
few features which are still
being under development
by the [INAUDIBLE]
institutes.
But which are still quite
interesting to talk about, and
we expect them to be available
in the near future.
Then we're going to look at six
decent mobile browsers,
notably Opera for Android,
the beta expression.
And these icons will be
displayed on most of the
slides, most of the
feature slides.
And if the logo is colored, then
the feature is available.
If it's grey and kind of light,
then clearly it's not.
So the screens on a mobile
device are smaller.
And this has a number
of constraints
which have put us--
well, not just on
us developers.
But it has constraints on
the end user, as well.
We're used to developing sites
from a desktop perspective.
And we've got all this screen
estate to play with.
And on a mobile device,
clearly, we
need to be more careful.
So the first thing to keep in
mind is that a browser by
default, mobile browser by
default, will assume that the
website you're visiting
is a desktop website.
This means that it will assume
that the width of the web page
will be equal to 980 pixels.
This kind of varies
per browser.
But for Chrome for Android,
it's 980 pixels.
The browser does this because
desktop websites have been
made with a decent
width in mind.
And if you suddenly decrease
the width of the page to be
much smaller than it originally
was, then the
website can completely
look distorted.
Text becomes unreadable.
And functionality becomes
unavailable.
So that's kind of an act we have
to do in order to make
the mobile web usable for
the vast majority
of the website today.
Of course, when you're
developing a mobile website,
this is not what you want.
You want a website to have the
width of the screen itself, so
you don't have horizontal
scrolling.
And the first thing you
should do is add a
meta viewport element.
The third example shows the
complete entry which you
should add to the pages.
It's actually quite simple.
You specify that the width of
your viewport should be equal
to the width of the device.
And you say that the initial
scales should be equal to one,
so that the user doesn't have
to zoom in before they can
read your content.
Now, editing a meta deck can
be a little bit awkward.
And especially if you want to
have several meta decks,
because your viewport has to
be slightly different for a
mobile phone or a
tablet device.
Then you probably have to resort
to either server side
detection of the device
or to JavaScript to
change it on the fly.
And that's just not cool.
So a feature which is currently
being developed is
called CSS Device Adaptation.
And this adds the Add Viewport
rule to CSS.
That viewport rule exposes
exactly the same information
as the meta element.
But it also allows you to change
that information using
the declaratives index, which
you're used to from CSS.
After all, the viewport
itself, it's more
presentational than
it is based on the
semantics of your page.
So it should be better
in CSS anyway.
Now, when you combine this with
Media Queries, which is a
cool trick allowing you to
have different sets of
styling, basic constraints after
the device user is using
to look at your website.
You can actually use Media
Queries to have several Add
Viewport rules based on, for
example, the width of the
device which is being used.
Let's look a little bit more
about these Media Queries.
They are kind of
an old feature.
Most of you will probably
already have used them in one
way or another.
But especially for mobile,
they're quite important.
Now the most basic example
probably is to have different
styling rules based
on the width and
the height of a device.
And you can have as many
constraints in
there as you want.
So you can have different
styling rules for tablets and
phones in its most basic uses.
You can select based on the
aspect ratio of a device.
In a television era, we all
remember the change from
normal 4 by 3 televisions
to 16 by 9 widescreen
televisions.
You still have an old TV.
And because of that, we want
to do this by black bars on
the television itself.
Now, if you have video content
on your page, you actually
might want to do exactly
the same.
And probably, the most
interesting one for today's
mobile devices is the resolution
directive.
The resolution directive allows
you to select based on
the pixel density
of the device.
You may already notice, using
the proprietary, WebKit
defines pixel ratio.
And based on that, you can have
different-- well, a good
use case for that could be to
have different images for high
resolution images such as Apple
retina screens, or the
newer Galaxy Nexus devices,
or for example, the
Galaxy Nexus S4.
A small note about the
resolution Media Query.
While it's upcoming, it's not
yet completely available in
all browsers.
But this index is way less
awkward than the old WebKit
device pixel ratio.
Now, all of these can probably
be used on desktop as well.
And this presentation, after
all, is about mobile.
So one directive which is
especially interesting for
mobile devices is the
orientation Media Query.
This allows you to have
different styling of the page
based on how the user is holding
the device, which can
change while they're watching
your website.
Of course, selecting based
on the viewport itself is
interesting.
But it would also be nice if you
can size elements or fonts
based on the width, the height
of the viewport.
Because of that, four
new units are being
introduced to CSS.
They're called the
viewport units.
There's VW for the width
of the viewports.
There's VH for the height
And then VMIN and VMAX which
respectively map to the
smallest and the largest
value of the two.
They work a little bit
like percentages.
So 100 VW will be equal
to the complete
width of the viewports.
Now, the viewport itself
is smaller.
We know about that.
And on a desktop machine, we
probably do have two 24 inch
monitors, at least we do.
But you'll at least have one.
And it's quite likely that
content on websites is being
displayed next to each other, or
often in multiple columns.
Just because all this screen
estate is available.
And it's really a shame if
you let it go to waste.
On a mobile device, this
is quite different.
You have a lot less space.
And content which can be
displayed next to each other
might actually be more
convenient if you display it
on top of each other
on a mobile device.
And the CSS Flexible Box
Module allows you to do
exactly this.
It allows you to reorder the
content on the fly, reorder it
based on putting an element
above the other using CSS, or
even changing the entire
flow of your content.
Now, one thing to keep in mind
is that the syntax of the
Flexible Box Module
changed recently.
And it's a little bit awkward,
but you may have to support
both the old and the new syntax
until enough browsers
hit the new syntax.
And we all know fixed
position elements.
They stick around on
your viewport.
Could be useful for like
a navigation bar.
But fixed position elements
have got a little brother
called sticky position
elements.
These behave like inline inflow
elements, just as if
they're relatively positioned,
unless the parent element
partially moves out of view.
In that case, the browser will
make sure that the sticky
positioned element kind of
sticks around in a few parts,
which is quite a cool feature
which is really useful for, as
an example, the address book
showed on the slide.
PAUL KINLAN: Cool.
So we said earlier on that
users are mobile.
And we're trying to talk about
the idea that they might not
always have an Internet
connection.
They might be in a place where
maybe they're on a train for
instance, where they go
through a tunnel.
And the Internet connection
dies.
And on the mobile web, just
generally that experience is
pretty bad.
So we're going to look at
a couple of different
technologies that you can use
today pretty much across all
of the mobile web to actually
accommodate the fact that your
users are mobile.
Now, I want to do
a little survey.
Who knows the Geolocation API?
OK, not actually--
I was expecting more people.
So anyway, the Geolocation API,
it's been around on the
web for quite a long time now.
And it's really good for
specializing content, for
instance, on new sites where
you'll say, where is the user?
Oh, they're based in the UK.
We're going to give them
UK based news.
Now, users, developers in
fact, always used to use
reverse IP look up.
On mobile, that's not as
applicable anymore.
And especially if you want to
get fine grained control of
where the user is and understand
where they are, you
need an API like the
Geolocation API.
And it's a pretty simple API.
You get Chrome composition.
And after a short time, it will
basically tell you the
users' code and location.
There's actually an accuracy
level, as well.
And kind of what Android does
as well at the moment is it
will give you that location
pretty quickly, but it's not
hugely accurate.
It might be within, say, 100
meters of where the user is.
If you want to get a more
accurate look on the user,
there's another API called Watch
Position, which actually
it does exactly what it says.
It watches the user's position
whilst they're on that page.
And it could be used for
situations where you're trying
to track the user when they're
walking down the street.
And you can update a map.
Or it could just be used
to get a final lock on
where the user is.
So you for instance could say,
well, the first request is
within 100 meters.
And then after a couple
of seconds--
and you'll probably
see from this demo
if it actually works--
the accuracy level changes.
So it goes from say an
accuracy level of 11
to 10 to 9 to 8.
And as it gets more accurate,
your position gets more and
more close to where
the user is.
PETER BEVERLOO: So if you saw
the keynote yesterday morning,
in the Android parts, they
introduced a new version of
the Google Play surfaces.
And this has a feature called
the User Location Profiler.
And the User Location Profiler
will actually mean that the
phone has a guessed position
of where the user is.
So Get Current Position will be
able to more quickly return
a more accurate position if you
use this new version of
the Android place of this.
PAUL KINLAN: So you know
where the user is.
And you're trying to not
necessarily track them but
understand where they are
so you can adapt your
application.
Device Orientation is another
feature that is available
pretty much across most
of the mobile web.
And device orientation, it's
a pretty simple API.
We saw the CSS before where you
could understand whether
the user was in portrait
or landscape mode.
The orientation events basically
fire whenever the
user moves their phone.
So if they're holding the
phone this way, you can
understand the angle, the
pitch, which is the beta
properly of how they're
holding their phone.
And you can also understand with
a relatively decent level
of accuracy their compass
location, which
is the alpha property.
And I think technically
it's called your.
It's pretty well supported
across the mobile web.
And you can use it today.
It's been around for about at
least a year and a half.
So we know where the user is.
And we're trying to help you
build applications which are
responsible to how they're
holding their phone.
The biggest problem that we face
in the mobile web with
regards to users on the
move is offline.
Now offline is super
important.
And if you're an application
developer, a native
application developer, you've
already got offline supported.
You build your applications to
work offline straight away.
And then integrate online
functionality in.
We as web developers, like,
everything is always online.
We go to a URL.
We always get it.
And it actually is pretty hard
to integrate offline
functionality into
our applications.
The first thing that we can do
though is we can look and
understand when the user is
either online or offline.
Now it's not entirely
accurate.
And you can understand exactly
when they're offline.
Because they have no network
connection, basically.
But the online state
is a little bit
more awkward, right?
You could be online.
You could be on a local network,
a Wi-Fi connection
but have no Internet
connection.
So the online event really just
basically means that you
have a connection
to a network.
It might not be a connection
to the Internet.
And there's a property that you
can want to see whether
you are online or not.
And this is great for when you
are building an application,
and the users going to
submit the form.
You can just basically
say, hey, you
can't submit this form.
You're offline.
So you can provide a nice little
bit of feedback there.
You go one step further.
You understand when the user
is online or offline.
They go to the URL bar.
They press Refresh.
And then they get this really
horrible gateway error or a
Chrome error that says like,
hey, no Internet connection.
You can't do anything.
That's a really bad
experience.
And that's one of the things
that's holding
the mobile web back.
Well, this application, or
Application Cache, this API
has been around for quite
a long time now.
And a lot of people
don't like it.
It's got a bit of a bad press.
But if you're building an
application which is like a
single page application, this
API will help you easily make
your application work offline.
And it does so by basically
listing a whole series of
files which encompass
your application.
It's called the application
manifest.
And in your HTML, you point
to the manifest using the
manifest attribute.
And the browser will then go
off, make sure all the assets
are available for offline use.
So when you press Refresh,
you'll still be able to get
your application.
And I must warn you, there's a
whole lot of photos of my face
entirely through this
presentation.
I guess it's the only one
we had rights to.
And he didn't want me to
do anything with his.
So anyway, so that's the
Application Cache.
There are a couple of
little caveats.
If you update any of your
assets, and then you expect
the user to be able to
get them, they won't.
They need to update the
manifest, or you need to
update the manifest for them
to go and get that data.
And if you cache the manifest
itself, you're just into a
whole heap of pain.
Because you'll never be able
to update the manifest,
because everyone will always
have the manifest--
oh, it's a nightmare.
Anyway, we have storage
APIs, right?
We have this idea that
our applications are
going to work offline.
And for them to work offline, we
need to make sure our data
is offline.
And you know, we're not actually
in a great position,
are we, on the mobile
web at the moment?
We have local storage.
Local storage, key value pair
system-- you can blobs of data
and strings of data and get
them out and fire a key.
And it's ubiquitous.
It's on every single
platform available.
However, you can't really do
any rich, powerful querying
semantics with it.
We have two other APIs, Web SQL
Database and Indexed Database.
Web SQL, it's kind of cool.
Everyone knows SQL.
Hands up if you know SQL?
See.
Are there any browser
vendors in here who
said, Web SQL's rubbish?
Everyone said it's cool.
So anyway, so Web SQL,
everyone knows SQL.
It's got rich querying
semantics.
However, it's not broadly
supported.
It's not yet--
it's in iOS, Android,
and Chrome.
But it's not in Firefox.
And it's not in Internet
Explorer.
And it's no plans
to be in there.
It's a deprecated API.
We have Indexed Database.
index Database is the way
that we're going to
store data in the web.
But it's not really
broadly supported.
It's not on iOS.
It's not on Android,
I think Chrome and
the rest of the browsers.
So what are you going to
do as a developer?
Well, the only sane solution
that we've got is to use
abstractions and use shims.
There are a couple of
shims out there.
Lawn Chair has been around
for a long, long time.
And it's basically a key value
pair system with some query
semantics, where you can plug
in your own custom providers
to say, hey, I want to
use Web SQL database.
Or hey, I'm going to use
Indexed Database.
And then there's two others,
asyncStorage, which is similar
to Lawn Chair, and then the
Indexed Database shim.
And the Indexed Database shim
basically says, you know what?
We're going to use the Indexed
Database API if it's there.
If it's not there, we're just
going to fall back to Web SQL.
And if you have that method,
where you can fall back from
Indexed Database to Web SQL, you
can cover pretty much all
the mobile web for
storing offline.
PETER BEVERLOO: So input on
a mobile device is harder.
We notice.
We don't write essays
on a mobile device.
And for the major share, they're
actually used for
consumption of data rather
than producing data.
Now, this shows when you have
a form on your website, even
if it's just a login form
or a form where a user
has to enter a number.
It's just awkward to enter it.
Especially on a mobile device
like a phone, you look at this
on screen keyboards, and it's
just basically awkward to use.
I often click on the
wrong letter.
And I've learned to rely on the
auto correction feature,
or even on the suggestions,
which can be displayed above
the keyboard itself, which is
something Android does.
Now, you've probably heard this
a million times already.
Use semantical input types.
It's quite simple.
Instead of using input type as
text, you use input type with
a more specialized type.
A good example of this is using
input types number.
If you want the user to enter
a number, which could be a
telephone number or a price or
anything else, you really
don't want to have them go
through the hassle of seeing
letters, chapters on their
keyboards, having to click on
shift, and then finding really
small buttons of the numbers.
Well, the phone has a perfectly
optimized keyboard
just showing numbers.
Now, a more extreme example
probably is data time input.
I'm from the UK, as is Paul.
And date and time, I believe
here you write month first and
then the day and
then the year.
For us, it's different.
From other countries, it's
different again.
PAUL KINLAN: I believe the UK
has the correct format.
PETER BEVERLOO: D is, that's
just to separate the
components of a date,
or D is slashes.
And really, it's just awkward.
And it's not just difficult for
the end user using your
website, but it's
also difficult
for you as a developer.
Because users give all these
days in random input types.
And you have to write
complicated procedures in your
back end to handle
all of them.
Now if you would just change
that input type as text to
input type as date or even input
type data and local.
Then the phone will be
able to do something
really smart and simple.
It's actually a no brainer.
It will show you a date
and time picker.
And by a date and time picker,
that makes it infinitely
easier to enter a data or time
for a site, and will give you
as a developer a more consistent
result when a user
submits that form
to the website.
Now, this doesn't just
result in more
convenience for the user.
Another additional benefit you
get from this is validation,
client side validation of
the input type itself.
But if a user somehow manages to
enter rubbish, the browser
will show a dialogue about, I
don't know what you're doing.
But this is not quite what the
website will be expecting.
You want to correct this.
And you can use attributes,
that's just min and max, to
actually impose a range based on
which number or which date
can be entered by
the end user.
Now, when I use my desktop
computer, I have this small
device next to me, a mouse.
And this gives me a cursor on
the screen itself, which is
incredibly accurate.
It's really convenient to use.
It allows me to select any
element or any position on my
screen with really
high accuracy,
Now, I don't know about you
guys, but in comparison to
that mouse pointer,
my finger is fat.
It's really fat.
It's inaccurate and it becomes
infinitely harder to click on
exactly the point on the
screen where I want.
And this has forced browsers
to implement alternative
solutions such as Chrome's
disambiguation pop up, which
basically zooms in on part of
the page, allowing you to
clarify what you mean.
Or for Safari, to have a number
of heuristics available
to think what you might want
to have clicked on.
Now, you can optimize
for this.
There are three primary
events available.
And that's Start, which will
be called when you put a
finger on the screen, On Touch
Move, when you actually move
on a screen, and On Touch End,
when you remove the finger
from the screen again.
And this allows you to optimize
your application for
touch inputs.
And maybe have a slightly bigger
error margins, because
it's more inaccurate.
Or have a different UI,
different handling all
together based on what a user
does with their fingers.
Now, there's one thing
to keep in mind here.
There is a small click delay
imposed by the browser.
When you tap on the screen
itself and remove your finger
again, that's a tap.
But there is this gesture
available in Chrome called
double tap to zoom.
Now, if you double tap on the
screen, it will zoom in to
that element.
And the page will not receive
a click element.
The browser needs a little bit
of time to actually figure out
whether you want to tap
once or tap twice.
And before it knows that,
it will wait.
And after that wait, it will
send to click event.
Now, 300 milliseconds is quite
a long time if you want to
have a responsive
user interface.
It's a number of frames.
It's actually 20 frames.
That's quite a lot.
So you should be really careful
with, well, you can
avoid it if you set a viewport
rule on your page.
And the next feature, Pointer
Events, also provides a
solution to this.
Pointer Events is a
specification which is still
in development, which unifies
certain concepts.
It unifies a concept of a mouse
pointer and touch inputs
and, for example, a stylus into
the concept of a pointer,
which really could be anything,
without losing too
much of the pointer specific
information or constraints.
The JavaScript imperative event
API is quite similar to
what we're used to from
mouse events.
Instead of mouse in the name,
you'll have pointer.
And it will allow you to
create a flow in your
application to handle both touch
inputs and mouse input
using the same code.
Now, this specification also
comes with a simple CSS
property called .action.
And if you specify .action as
none on any element, you will
actually tell the browser that
if the user taps on exactly
that element, that the
browser shouldn't
do any default action.
And thereby, the double click to
zoom just here won't work.
And because it won't work, the
browser doesn't have to wait
300 milliseconds.
And can immediately forward
to defend that click
event to the browser.
Quite related but not
specifically part of the
Pointer Event specification
are the pointer directives
available from Media Queries.
And by specifying point of
course for fingers or pointer
find from mouse pointers, you
can actually have different
sets of styling based on whether
the device the user is
viewing your websites
with is capable of a
certain kind of input.
Pixel supports both.
So there is a little bit
of trickery you have to
keep in mind here.
PAUL KINLAN: One quick point.
Are we actually implementing
this in Chrome?
PETER BEVERLOO: There was an
intent to implement which we
received from Microsoft.
PAUL KINLAN: But that
doesn't mean we're
implementing it just yet.
PETER BEVERLOO: We're
implementing parts of it.
PAUL KINLAN: Oh.
OK.
Cool.
So each of our devices has
unique capabilities such as
GPS, a location which we saw
earlier for the Geolocation
API, and cameras, and a whole
host of other things.
What can we take advantage
of on the web today?
And what is pretty ubiquitous?
Well, like two years ago, we
also spoke about this.
And no one seems
to be using it.
But you can actually take
pictures used from the user's
phone using the simple input
type equals file, and put the
capture attribute at
the top there.
And what that essentially
indicates to the browser or
the user agent is that you
should be able to pick whether
you're going to take a
picture or something
from the user's gallery.
And I've actually set up
my Android device here.
Like I said, I'm vain.
So there's obviously lots
of pictures of me.
My Android device, you have to
automatically use the camera.
But it's really cool,
this API.
Because it's like a
normal input type.
If there's no support for the
camera there, it'll just let
you pick just from
the gallery.
Now, the really cool, cool
thing about this is that
because it's a dom element,
there's an on change event
which happens which allows you
to get access to the raw data
that was delivered from the
file system into your
application.
And then you can manipulate it
however you want using the
file reader and file
writer APIs.
The logical extension to this,
and the thing that we found
from native applications at
least anyway, is that
developers don't really want
to have their applications,
and users don't want them
either, to have to go out from
one application and jump into
another application just to
take a picture.
They want this nice, seamless,
integrated experience.
Well, part of the WebRTC
specification is getUserMedia.
And getUserMedia delivers you
basically video and audio
streams from the
user's webcam.
Now, the really nice thing about
this is you're sitting
there going, it's the
video stream.
It's not really a picture.
Well, the code's not in here.
And it's inside the demo, but
you'll basically be able to
take a picture from the video
stream by just attaching it to
a canvas element.
And you can take it
out from there.
So you have integrated access
to the user's web cam inside
their phone just by using
this simple API.
It's kind of in Chrome.
It's actually in Chrome 5.
So hopefully it will be
enabled pretty soon.
But it's actually supported
across Firefox and other
browsers, as well.
So it's getting there.
It's pretty nice.
You can always fall back
to the other API.
The other one is Android
Intents.
If you're building an
application for Android, you
normally know the Android
Intents system pretty well.
Now, what you normally do is
you can communicate between
apps by asking for an action
that says, I need an app that
supports sharing.
And that's cool.
Now, the common thing is we
don't really have that on the
web anymore.
But we have this idea of,
well, my Android device
supports intents.
Can I invoke an intent
from the web?
Well, you can.
And it's supported in
the Android browser
and the Chrome browser.
And it allows us to open
applications from our site.
So if you've built a native
application, you can just
basically encode a special
URI, which is the intent
call-on sequence, make sure your
application supports the
browsable category, which
basically means, my
application's allowed to be
opened by the browser.
And any link that has this
scheme will be able to open up
an application directly inside
the user's machine or inside
their device.
The really cool thing for me on
this side of things is the
application isn't installed.
Because you have to include
the package name of your
application.
You can actually direct the
user automatically to the
Android store.
And that's a pretty cool, pretty
powerful API to have
when you want to get the user
to install your native
application as well, by the
site of your web based
application.
And this demo is just
the QR code app.
It's not just a normal camera.
It's an application that
obviously uses the camera, but
is dedicated to taking
QR codes.
And we've integrated with that
with just that one line of
code inside the Android
browser in Chrome.
Now one of the cool things about
native applications is
that your application
like basically takes
up the entire screen.
You don't have this horrible,
well it's not
horrible URL bar.
That's the wrong thing to say.
It's like this awkward little
URL bar for your applications,
normally with a forward and
backwards button and a refresh
and all this type of stuff.
Your application or game takes
up the entire screen.
Well, this is coming
to Chrome as well.
But basically, we have the
actual WebKit request full
screen API implemented in
Chrome, which allows you to
take any DOM element and
make it full screen.
And this demo here, I've got
the ability to take the
document, the entire page, or a
single element, which is an
image, and make it
full screen.
And there's an API which
actually cancels that out.
So you can actually back
it up pretty easy.
The other thing you'll notice
on the Chrome browser for
Android is that we don't
actually yet support Scroll2,
which is an iOS idiom basically
where you can push
the address bar out the way.
We don't support it yet, we
will do soon in some later
builds, at least.
That's right, isn't it?
Yeah, we will definitely
support it.
Which means that if you've got
an application which tries to
push it out the way,
it'll work.
And you'll have the same
experience inside the Chrome
for Android browser.
PETER BEVERLOO: So a biggest
mobile device is much smaller
just in its physical size.
And we can't put in all these
fancy GPUs and big components
which are actually quite fast.
There are a number
of limitations.
Now, if you've been to the
Chrome stand upstairs, we
categorize these limitations
in three categories.
Firstly, computational
limitations.
For example, in JavaScript,
execution speed.
Rendering limitations in fast
scrolling or displaying your
website in a quick way.
But both of these have been
covered by a number of other
presentations already.
And you can definitely go back
to YouTube after Google I/O
and watch these presentations.
We want to look at two APIs
which are quite relevant to
the network aspect
of limitations.
Because the user can be on
the move at all times.
Let's look at what happens
when a user
navigates to a new page.
Now, this could be because
they enter a URL in their
address bar.
Or this could be because
they click on a link.
When a navigation
start, the first
part will be the network.
During this network phase, the
browser will have to figure
out the DNS of your
web server.
So it will have to change to a
domain name and an IP address.
It will have to say hello
to the server.
Basically, I want resources.
Are you ready for me?
And this takes some time.
Now after this, it will start
loading the page.
It will start sending messages
to the server about exactly
which resources it wants.
Unless of course, it finds
a redirection.
When it does so, it restarts
the navigation based on
exactly the URL, which is
one to redirect to.
And that's valuable time
which is lost.
And after it's loading and it
got the code of the research
itself, it will start
to process the data.
And for an HTML file, this
could, for example, means that
it starts to build a dom.
Now, there are a number
of things which
could be slow here.
And the only way to really
be sure of what
is slow is to measure.
So the Navigation Timing API
exposes a lot of data on all
these items which allow you to,
with great accuracy, see
what parts of loading the page
are taking out a lot of time.
And this is actually reflected
in dev tools, as well.
You can open dev tools in any
page, and it allows you to see
the same in the Timeline
panel.
Now, when I create a website,
it's not just a page of HTML
which I will be delivering
to my users.
I will have images.
I will have style sheets.
I'll probably have JavaScript
files as well, in some cases.
And the resource timing API is
quite complementary to the
Navigation Timing API, except
that it contains information
about the timing of several
resources being load by the
page instead of just
the page itself.
This gets you much more high
fidelity information about
each resource.
And it will allow you to quickly
identify scripts or
just allows you to file switcher
blocking the loading
of your page.
PAUL KINLAN: So we've seen some
amazing pictures of my
face throughout this entire
presentation.
And I really do apologize
for that.
But I want to kind of highlight
some of the newer
features that are coming
to the web platform.
We've seen a lot of things
which, basically we've tried
to say that the web platform on
mobile is just as competent
as the desktop platform.
But there are a couple of areas
where we've been kind of
a little bit behind.
And we're going to show you
some of these, which are
experiment with features that
are available inside Chrome.
The first is obviously the
extension to getUserMedia
called WebRTC.
Now, a lot of people have heard
about this in the sense
that you can take one video
stream, audio stream, and pass
it directly to another phone or
another device or another
desktop machine without
having to proxy it
through your own service.
That's cool.
That's like the peer
connection stuff.
That's always, well, that's been
on the desktop side of
things for a little while.
One area that we don't really
talk about but it's actually
landed in Chrome and
a couple of other
browsers is the data channel.
And the data channel allows you
to send data directly from
one application to another.
And there's a talk tomorrow by
Sam Dutton which is going to
cover a lot of this area
around WebRTC.
We can't do it justice today.
But it is coming.
And you can try it inside Chrome
flags today, inside
Chrome already.
If you're a developer, my
recommendation is, I don't
really like the API that much,
but WebRTC to IO and EasyRTC.
These APIs, these abstractions
on top of it, they work really
well, and allow you to build
these type of applications in
just a couple of
lines of code.
The next is Web Audio.
Games developers have been
wanting this for ages.
Because they want to build real
time kind of low latency
audio into their platform.
And I'm not going to go into too
much again because it's a
very long and complex subject.
But it gives you near real
time access to the audio
streams and the audio data that
you can manipulate inside
the JavaScript.
And this is coming to
the mobile platform.
Right now, it's only
available on--
I need to get this right-- on
devices supporting the neon
chipset, which just kind of
luckily happens to be a large
number of devices
at the moment.
And that's one of the reasons
why we're still keeping it
behind the flags as well,
because it's not broadly
available just yet.
And it still needs some
time to bake.
And WebGL.
This is a demo by the guys
that play Canvas.
They built it in about
a day or so.
But essentially, there's WebGL
support inside Opera, I
believe, and Firefox, which
allows you to build these 3D
rich interactive games.
And if you combine that with
WebRTC and Web Audio, you can
build these really kind of
cool collaborative games.
You name it, you can build
it, and it'd be cool.
So we are nearly finished
now, aren't we?
Pretty cool.
We're running close on time.
I want to ask one question.
Do you want to ask it?
PETER BEVERLOO: So is the
mobile web awesome yet?
PAUL KINLAN: Is it awesome?
Who said no?
Oh.
This is supposed to be a rally
call to yes, it is.
So we can?
PETER BEVERLOO: We can adapt to
the various screen sizes of
mobile devices.
We know that screen sizes of
mobile devices are smaller.
They have limitations.
But there's plenty of features
available for us to
restructure content based on
that, or to work around these
constraints to bring a proper
user experience to your users.
PAUL KINLAN: We can accommodate
users on the
move-- the Geolocation API,
the offline access APIs.
We can build applications that
are responsive to users being
on the move.
PETER BEVERLOO: We can
speed up inputs.
It's awkward, but we can
make it as easy for
the user as is possible.
PAUL KINLAN: And we
can integrate with
all the device features.
You have access to the camera.
You have access to GPS and a
whole lot of other features on
the mobile web today that are
ubiquitous across the platform.
PETER BEVERLOO: We can measure
exactly where in our
applications the pain
points are.
Now, I know that we just
looked at some network
specifications related
to the network.
But there's a lot we can
do to actually figure
out why it's slow.
PAUL KINLAN: And we can look
forward to WebRTC,
Web Audio, and WebGL.
So I think in summary, we
believe that web on the mobile
web is absolutely awesome.
Thank you very much.
PETER BEVERLOO: Thank you.
PAUL KINLAN: I'm going
to say, we do have
three minutes for questions.
It's probably best if we take
them off stage or outside.
Me and Peter will be
available for any
questions that you do have.
Thank you.